[Music]
and welcome back to the careful boys
y'all were extremely careful most
careful showing the internet today we
have don
yeah dawn
how you doing man good bro how you doing
hey get this water bottle out of the
frame dude you professional last time
you were here was it for ask the expert
no he did a jk news with us before it
might have been the same day
yeah but anyways don owns a company
called deep end fitness and they do
really cool training in the pool he's
also a former raider which is uh marine
special operations and he's a sexy dude
and now
he's a las vegas raider he's a no and
he's about to graduate uh
from his mba program wow just crushing
it in life where uh what's school at usc
that's ty
congratulations nice dude this must be
proud man
because my parents are okay with my
career choices
okay
they're different how does it feel
like to [ __ ] crush life
[Laughter]
i don't know i would ask you the same
same thing bro
nobody believes that nobody believes
that dog did you get resistance from
your parents when you wanted to join the
military yeah what do they say oh they
didn't want you to join no i mean like i
would say it's like half half between
like hey you need to do something with
your life don't be a [ __ ] up and then
another half was like don't go don't do
that don't go to war that's so crazy but
you went hard you weren't even like yo
i'm gonna go there and be like
a medic you're like i'm a go there and
be a marine raider like you could have
chose a job that was like you know i
would be the guy that's creating
internet
out there i mean like or something else
i want to be that guy right now
like let me go let me be the guy that's
like the modem guy maybe i'll cook for
the guys you know like
you know you're doing your service but
you're not quite having bullets you know
being shot at you
but you chose the let me go in to get
shot at yeah yeah how did that progress
i've always been like
addicted to like kind of adrenaline rush
but even out of like the branches why
did you choose the marine corps and then
why did you choose to become a raider
after that uh the marine corps i think
it was like they have a really high
heritage and like tradition kind of
sense of being the best unit or the best
function in the military so i believe
that and i went in that and then i did
that for the four years and then
also wanted to do something else because
i don't think that the marine corps
infantry was like where i belonged i
want to do something better or something
greater so then
so you're like you're like marine corps
is the best you did and you're like it's
all right
any better yeah was it did you is it
because when you went into them that's
pretty baller is it because when you
went to the military you're like wait
there's higher levels to this and then
you're like what yeah i honestly didn't
even know like anything about the
military when i joined [ __ ]
recruiters suck huh yeah well [ __ ] my
recruiter is all right though yeah he
pulled me out of jail once so whoa we're
gonna give credit to him yeah were we in
jail for stealing dvds at uh
ontario mills
[Music]
are you stealing dvds why not you just
wanted it just for the rush just just
for the rush really he's an adrenaline
junkie he just said it stealing dvd's
how did he bail you out like you saw a
guy in a uniform come and he was like
he's with me he could be yeah
they took me to the mall jail and then
they took me to uh the regular jail and
like hey your mom needs to come pick you
up you know from the thing we're not
gonna press charges or anything like
that and then i called my mom and that
was like the third time that year so she
was like oh sh [ __ ] no i'm not picking
you up anymore then i have to call my
recruiter that's tight your mom was like
i'm not picking you up what made you
want to call your recruiter you guys
were tied like that he was pretty cool
so he was like if you need anything
let me know because i need you to hit my
quota yeah
that's right i mean you know that's
exactly why you know but i mean at least
he did that though so that was pretty
cool it defined the quota what's the
what's the question like when you're a
recruiter um you do have like like
numbers you're trying to hit like in all
aspects of the military like there's
metrics you're trying to hit to advance
to promote right like in any job yeah so
as a recruiter you also have that and
like they have like districts and stuff
that like
in this district that you you need to
hit a certain number or whatever and i
only know that because i've worked at
some recruiting stations i got injured
and stuff and then um
there'll be times where like they're
like hey that guy's vietnamese hey quan
go talk to their family and convince
them i'm like i'm chinese uh yeah but
you guys like look the same you know you
guys that's [ __ ] up
you guys you talk to him he's right now
he's right yeah
that's actually how it happens and then
yeah so that's they have like quotas and
stuff they're gonna send a white guy
over there
seriously if a recruiter is like i
[ __ ] recruited like x amount like
killed it they'll get just uh promoted
to
what's uh
example of a quota like what's the
number senior recruiter so i don't know
it could be like it could be like no so
what happens is like in the recruit so
you got to think like uh in every part
of the military there's an entire
like section
like a operating sys like almost like
like you know like the executive branch
let's just lay the friends the entire
branch right so in the like recruiting
system what you see in like little
plazas that's like the bottom
then you have like the where they
actually was meps right yeah where they
actually like uh do the physicals and
stuff and then you have like an entire
just i'm pretty sure there's a
commanding general in charge of
recruiting probably right yeah for sure
yeah so it's just like the entire system
training them training so there's the
latter marketing the latter and every
single thing okay if you're killing it
here then you can you know be like the
recruiter of recruiters and then go to
like the mep system and kind of like
work your way up in that department
pretty much finding people for it
because oh god
go do your
spitting mostly just like cold calling
like how do they like find people they
set up pull-up bars in high schools yes
that's the most so the one that's in the
mall you do the pull-up bar competition
i've done it i've done the competition
yeah you did yeah you do like high
school they'll give you a t-shirt
they're like nice we don't need you and
they took me
i couldn't even jump up i couldn't even
reach and grab it yeah that was the
problem the ones at the mall what are
they doing in that office all day that's
what they do they're recruiting and oh
but the when they're sitting in there
like they they're just setting up
different tricks that's like for
walk-ins
i really like would look at him as like
as it works across the hallway and the
the mall is like i don't want to work at
the mall anymore dude i'm gonna walk
across the way
i used to always like look in there and
be like they're just sitting there
they're not asking yeah so like the mall
cop is like that's my dream i'm gonna
walk into that office
one day one day i'm gonna get the
courage to do that
yeah they're probably doing paperwork or
they already hit their quota for so they
don't actually walk through the mall and
go hey you want to be they're not the
mall but to high schools
definitely do cold calls yeah for sure
uh recruiters are born we're talking
about raiders here uh what's it right
here
uh yeah just a special for someone
that's dumb there's no [ __ ] can you
explain to me i'm a marvel avenger and
that's a different branch yeah which
which one are you i did the marketing
you're doing a good job bro yeah you're
killing it you're crushing it explain to
him what a raider is and why you joined
the avenger after yeah it's just uh the
special operations arm of the marine
corps so like the navy has the seals the
army has the green berets or the rangers
uh the air force has their pjs it's just
this special operation oh so like what's
some what's some special operations are
you doing
what
is there a statistic of like is there a
statistic with showing how many marines
actually make it to uh raider that try
to get it um i think there's there's a
quota of how many guys they need to get
through depending on like the demand of
the unit uh of that time right if
there's increasing forces needed to go
over to key areas in the world like
during iraq and afghanistan there's a
huge push to recruit more people in but
also to get more guys to special
operations to get more guys in every
functioning unit that goes and deploys
and kicks down doors and like do that
kind of stuff but
is that like everybody who joins marine
corps tries to get there or is that like
no everybody has their own job right
it's just one specific job got it right
when you walk through a day in the life
of what a raider would do they're like
you get the call all right you're going
to somewhere right so then you go okay
you can't tell your family
[Music]
right it just depends yeah it depends
what mission set you're going on and
where you're going in the world so how
do you get the call you get the call
you're like hey boy
you're activated
like born identity where it's like
you're you're in a corporate meeting
you're like baby no it's not like
[ __ ] i've been retired already don't
come back after me you've smoked a
cigarette too they're like we need y'all
you're the only one that could do it and
you're like god damn it damn it
and then you're looking at your wife
you're like i gotta go get some more ice
and then it's a montage of how you're
training to get back into [ __ ]
yeah dude
without i guess really revealing too
much i know you guys got secrets to keep
what is a general like
day-in-the-life job of like what a
raider does like
when they're working or like what you
know like like assassinating bad guys or
whatever like
working or assassinating yeah every day
is different if you're in the united
states if you're overseas and then
overseas depends where you're at what
kind of mission you're doing so are you
doing missions in the u.s or just
training never in the u.s right so let's
say you're overseas and you already know
it's
it's not fun over there
what's a day in the life like that yeah
what time do you wake up yeah like in
afghanistan let's just use the day like
that for example when when i was over
there i mean sometimes you have guard
duties you're standing in a tower by
yourself for like four hours
in the middle of the like [ __ ] 360
view you get shot from anywhere like
that kind of [ __ ] i would say you have
one corner of it depends where you're at
right if you're in a bad area then
everybody has to stand
guard right
um and then you wake up eat breakfast
maybe get a workout in or something with
some weights and then uh today's video
is brought to you by curology
all right guys i've been on this for
several years now
and it's a pretty easy regimen to do
but i also think that for skin care a
lot of guys
lack in that department a little bit and
it's not their fault i think it's just
hard because the more you have to think
about stuff right and then you have all
these options you have to go to the
store you have to get it when it's like
you need to refill it all this stuff i
think it gets confusing in the research
and everything at least that's how i am
and if you're failing on your skin and
you're you're not really staying on top
of that beautiful glistening nice
beautiful sexual self you know what's
going to end up happening right
you're going to be an old wrinkle old
raisin and i don't want that and you
don't want that so definitely go ahead
and check this out we have wonderful
wonderful curology
products here to save your life so guys
if you want ultra easy skincare that's
actually made for your skin curology is
the way to go you'll get a custom
prescription cream made for you by
dermatology provider for your specific
goals whether that's tackling acne
clogged pores skin texture dark spots
fine lines or something else you start
by taking a short online skin quiz and
if it's a good fit they'll ship you your
formula right to your door get started
with curology just like i did with a
free 30-day trial at curology.com
off the record just pay five dollars for
shipping and handling that's
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y dot com slash off the
record to start your free 30-day trial
cancel any time prescription subject to
consultation what's breakfast like
middle eastern food or mre or what yeah
so when i was living in a village you're
eating middle eastern food like a goat
sandwich goat a lot of like flat bread
cucumber salad that sounds good it's
actually nice not bad yeah um and then
you go on if you go visit like some
village elders
establish delay of the land and then at
night you go on a mission depending what
you do for maybe two three days you come
back what's a typical mission like
what's like a regular mission that's not
that like sexy and what's like what's
crazy it's a sexy message it goes out
there appreciate the bible stuff
so like going to a village
elder's meeting might be admission right
because you're there to go get a key
specific piece of information and a sexy
one might be like hey we got that piece
of information now we develop it we
confirm where the bad guy is that we're
talking about and then the sexy one
would be going there and killing that
bad guys
so most of it is like it's you're trying
to break this dude but you don't know
his whereabouts so the other missions
are just get gathering the intel and all
the stuff
to put together a plan
so there's a lot of politics and maybe
even spy [ __ ] going on where you got to
get so much information to like create a
plan yeah i mean it's like everything
every other job like hey i thought it
was gonna be like rambo bro
like i thought you're gonna go in like
plan
i mean if you're getting attacked and
trying to get someone's trying to
overrun you then it would be like i
thought you guys get dropped off in the
helicopter and your team is just [ __ ]
like called on the way down with the
parachute
[Laughter]
sometimes but not when you kill someone
and you loot them real quick you pick up
all your supplies and you get more
points okay then you tea bag
just kidding just kidding yeah that's a
workout
so here's a real question right because
like when you watch all these movies
you don't realize that you know soldiers
are also human and they cut out the
things like we get travel diarrhea
like when we when we're out and we're
eating foreign food right
you're gonna eat like a goat sandwich
maybe a lot of the times if you're on
american diet you're gonna get travel
diarrhea did you get diarrhea from the
first goat sandwich so how do how do
military guys deal with that you're like
in war and then you're like oh oh
you got bubble guts on the battlefield
you know there's serious questions we
need to suck it up i mean but they also
prevent a lot of it do you just [ __ ]
yourself i've definitely [ __ ] myself you
just [ __ ] in your pants and just you
have to because you can't leave your
post i mean like you can get someone to
relieve you that would probably be the
best way so you can watch yourself if
you're like on a mission you're in a
sight like there's nothing you can do
huh there's nothing you can do you might
have to [ __ ] in a pvc pipe
sometimes why can't you just [ __ ] on the
floor because then if you're in a hide
site and you're trying to like do a
reconnaissance on
you don't want to leave your evidence
you don't leave
you can evidence the trail see how much
of a [ __ ] you already even know that
kind of [ __ ]
or you honestly need to fix your hat
before you call me a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that was a good anthony burn bro
i'm team anthony now bro were you a
specialist in any specific weapon my job
was the communications guy and the uh
what we call a jtac which is the joint
tactical
terminal attack controller so i called
in the aircrafts for the airstrikes
so you give coordinates like cool
forty five forty six twenty seven seven
eight eight
is that really like uh
is there really like a laser sight thing
that you can point a coordinate out is
that a real thing
uh when you're calling an air strike
it's like a ir pointer which just shoots
like a laser but infrared so you can't
really see with the human eyes but the
aircrafts can see it or night vision you
can see it there's actually like a laser
device that shoots a
coated laser code
that shoots out and then you have to
keep it on the target and then the bomb
will identify that laser code on the
battlefield and then it will track in on
that later that's the coolest thing i
think my tax dollars paid for one of
those yeah
now that's that's tax dollars well
coolest uh toy that you got to like play
with
um
shooting rockets are pretty fun you mean
like this kind of rocket yeah that kind
of rockets we gave a lot to ukraine
right give a [ __ ] tonight yeah cause
they're just blowing up tanks all day
you ever have like eyes on target right
you're about to shoot the guy like the
bad guy
and then right when he pulled the
trigger he goes up i gotta pick up this
thing
i do it again and then he goes
[Laughter]
if
[Laughter]
what do you feel like your uh your super
power for your unit was obviously
there's like your your specific job but
like what do you feel like your
superpower is
um
your liabilities it's good to stay calm
in the stressful situations
i would for sure [ __ ] myself was that
something you had prior to military
like a natural ability to kind of
become in crazy situations i think like
when i was stealing clothes and [ __ ] i
always got the adrenaline rush and still
able to kind of like think what the
process like what i need to do oh you
used to shoplift quite a lot i did yeah
so do you think that helped you prepare
in a lot of weird ways i think like it
just helps you like hey to think fast on
your feet like what can i do in this
situation it's like a gradual onslaught
you're like eric bana and black hawk
down but stealing clothes out of a mall
i had this exact conversation yesterday
because i was talking about some of my
friends who were just like hardcore
like
they did burglaries all this stuff and
then they they turned out to be great
human beings when they became older and
i was like
i feel like
white kids had an outlet of extreme
sports they'll do the crazy stuff and
like get all that you know youthful
adrenaline out whereas a lot of minority
kids will get into gang stuff and then
like that high adrenaline stuff was
always realized in gang life and then
it's like but now it's like you have way
more people doing like extreme sports
but i think that outlet is hella
important for young males if you have
that desire because i remember doing a
lot of stupid [ __ ] and it would progress
it's like
when you're jumping into people's
backyards right and then later on maybe
you might look if the doors is open so
you go inside because it's fun or
whatever and it just goes into stealing
like maybe you're stealing [ __ ] as a kid
and you're like you know what this is
really profitable it's free maybe i
could just walk in and grab a tv and run
out and it goes crazier and crazier and
crazier but it's like if you could
channel that in something healthy man
that'd be so cool i once watched this
video like this white navy seal dude and
then they asked him like how did you
know he wanted to be a navy seal and he
was like well i found out that
it's legal for us to overthrow a
government he goes i'm in
so it was just like for him it's illegal
because he's been breaking into random
things and just do crazy [ __ ] yeah he's
like wait you're telling me i get to be
paid to be a ninja and overthrow the
government with just a few people it's
like i meant that when you say it like
that that's you know
that is a pretty cool way to think i
regret being too woke in high school
because um i had dreams to being in the
military right so in junior high and all
that i was starting to buy like you
remember soldier of fortune magazine all
that stuff and i'll start i was starting
to study this [ __ ] right and then i
became a [ __ ] communist and when i
was a freshman because
and then also i started learning about
like oh dude hella mercenaries at the
time before anyone even knew about
al-qaeda a lot of u.s
people who just wanted military training
so they could start doing contracting
work a cheaper way to do it was to join
military camps of like terrorist groups
and then they would go get hired at like
these military contracting groups well
not military they're security
contracting groups that like foreign
nations will hire and they'll get uh
ex-military guys to just private uh
mercenaries like black water and stuff
yeah and i'm like damn this is crazy and
then the more i got into it i was like
man if i joined the us military they're
gonna use me dude
and then it's all over the thoughts of
like 14 year old joe yeah
he's like which militia should i join in
order to fight something
to write something yeah had a tapioca
express
just thinking about it i just wanted to
play soldier man
and then i got to the the side i was
like how do i get to play soldier but
like not really and i was like the coast
guard really the coast guard is the one
man
that was the one you should have joined
the coast guard dude yeah the u.s coast
guard but i don't know i think that's
pretty awesome though cause like
um that's one thing i think uh everyone
should actually just try to do
is is
go through boot camp yeah just mandatory
boot camp you don't have to join the
military just [ __ ] go just to do it
because i want to do that
i don't know if i'm allowed to write i
think it'll benefit more people than i
don't want to do that because you know
some countries they have a mandatory
like two-year
like all-male central military how do
you feel about that you think that's a
good idea for for like just the general
public i think i think that makes sense
sometimes when i think of like uh like
obviously south korea is very popular
every every boy has to and if you don't
you like you're [ __ ] going to jail or
some random [ __ ] right but then you also
think about that and you think about
like the size of their like island
nation almost and you think about like
they're all one nation of people yeah
that's right like one ethnic group so
they have to like represent all one
unified thing
and then on top of that too population
size for their like you know per capita
compared to like another giant country
like america it like makes way more
sense for
it it makes a lot of sense to be like
everybody needs to be trained if we want
to have a fighting chance some countries
you can choose
military or you can be fire or like
police as well yeah because it does
build a certain level of patriotism i
think i'll be a mailman yeah like giving
back to the community kind of i'll be a
mailman raider
kind of like uh
like understanding that we're all one
ecosystem yeah versus i think in a
country that doesn't have it it's easy
to go like what's in it for me the whole
way through yeah yeah
i'm kind of conflicted because a part of
me is like
i love this country and i want to
freaking if it's time to get activated
we all got to go we all got to do it
right but then the other part of me is
like who's in charge profiting from this
decision
because i think the whole bush [ __ ] them
making a ton of money going into all
these you know countries a lot of
military dudes basically died so the
bush family can become rich and i'm like
why that's [ __ ] up you know like if
it's if it's really really
to preserve our freedoms and people were
attacking us then i'm like oh a thousand
percent that makes sense to you know
protect our community but then now i'm
like oh [ __ ] i don't know man like is it
is it worth it is it not worth it i'm
kind of coming way that i see it it's
like a paid internship you know like you
who knows what apple's really doing yeah
but you go there to develop all the
tools so like the amount of tools that
this guy has oh as an individual yeah
like the amount of tools like being able
to jump out of an airplane go underwater
shoot all kinds of different weapons
understand how to read a map like
a rocket rocket like just the tools that
he has as a human being that you get
it's invaluable yeah it's like unmatched
in any at the risk of being used as a
tool exactly just that's what i'm saying
like as a paid intern at apple right
like but i guess the death part is what
makes it
like not so much an internship for me or
i'm like if i'm acting quite the
opposite actually but that's that's the
i guess it's the territory of the
decision that i make but then i guess if
we're talking about mandatory because
that's kind of what we're talking about
is everyone's doing it mandatory then
i'm like i hope to god we have a
politician that's like not doing it and
using the military for their own gain
yeah and then hopefully we have someone
that's actually doing it because it's
like
you know we need to protect the country
yeah if all the politicians went through
the military they wouldn't treat the
military yeah like tulsi gabbard bro
tulsi gabbard's amazing right now so
true yeah i'm giving the thumbnail
another argument is like um
presidents that have kids
before we go and wage war with another
country make sure your kid is in that
war
you know like if like if this is
something that you're willing to put the
nation to start some [ __ ] better than
you gotta bet with your own money too
and they can't be protected in like it's
only for photo op like they have to be a
part of a unit
we have to fight side by side with them
the whole time
politicians are just gonna have war kids
then yeah yeah they'll be like all right
you're a war kid you guys i love you
you're a regular kid
hunter biden
over there
[Music]
you